um so let's start with the background to
this which is Thames water is the UK's
biggest uh water provider one in four
people rely on it but it has a mountain
of debt 14 billion pounds of debt around
10 percent of which uh becomes due at
the end of this year a bond matures at
that that's one of the reasons why the
company has been attempting we
understand to raise around a billion
pounds from its shareholders which
include a couple of very big pension
companies one in Canada one here the
university uh pensions fund looks after
lecturers and the like as well as a
couple of sovereign wealth funds Abu
Dhabi and China uh that may explain why
yesterday afternoon completely
unexpectedly its chief executive Sarah
Bentley resigned she was well into a
turnaround plan she she called it she'd
been talking about it publicly just a
couple of weeks ago did not feel like a
planned uh departure she's faced a lot
of pressure over the size of her
remuneration so she wouldn't take a
bonus but she was taking reportedly
massive pay packet north of 1.5 million
pounds huge public disquiet particularly
over the issue of sewage discharges now
we understand the government is
concerned less about what's been pumped
into the rivers than the money that may
or may not be in terms is control so
discussions contingency plans at an
early stage we understand around a
special Administration as it's called
you'll remember that bulb the big energy
provider was put into special
Administration rather than allowing it
to collapse what does the special
Administration allow it allows the
government effectively to underwrite the
company to keep it going to ensure that
service remains provided to customers
water coming into homes and sewage going
out in the other direction
without interruption while a buyer is
found in a rescue packages put together
and we've had a statement from the
government this morning a government
spokesman I'm afraid I can't see all of
it but it says that this is effectively
a matter for the company and its
shareholders so a response initially it
would appear and I would like to bring
you more of it uh it would appear the
initial response is that this is a
matter for terms but of course it's a
huge issue
for the government and a huge issue for
the water regulator off what and they
have been in number 11 or certainly
somewhere meeting the chance of the
exchecker Jeremy Hunt this morning this
meeting was called with off what the
water regulator off com the
communications regulator governs
broadband and the like Communications
and off gem which is we are familiar
looks after the energy Market as well as
the financial conduct Authority in the
competition markets Authority all of
them are The Regulators of stencil to be
the reason for it was the cost of living
the chancellor looking to remind them
perhaps for public appearance as much
for internal Communications as anything
to ensure that companies as prices begin
to fall uh they are those price Falls as
inflation needies are passed on to
customers uh off what it's a timely
meeting that the regulator should be in
there given the attention really very
squarely on the Water Industries morning
and therein lies the challenge of a
privatized water industry we want to
deliver value to customers and keep
bills down down and allow companies to
take a profit from a market which in
fact there isn't a great deal of
competition you can't choose supervise
your water well ultimately you are going
to face a question about how much can be
invested to improve infrastructure
particularly around sewage and that's
the challenge that's why so many water
all the water companies have such
enormous amounts of debt Thames water
has got a flood of it question is
whether the company will go under